right it's one of the doctors here
you're at kingston hospital
right you're just waking up and coming
around you're doing really really well
a soft gentle reassurance
so much compassion in the face of such
a relentless surge you're doing really
really well
this is one of kingston hospital's
intensive care units
it has two and they're both at
or near capacity
one nurse told me staff here are on
their knees
we're double the normal capacity and the
patients are a lot sicker than we
normally see
that emotional impact on staff seeing
patients lose their battle every day
that's difficult
yeah that's obviously happening on a
more regular basis than we used to
and unfortunately we just have to deal
with it and move on to the
move on to the people who are still with
us we still need our help this ward is
full of patients lying motionless
and intubated it's the same in hospitals
all over the country doctor after doctor
nurse after nurse icu
after icu and they're all telling us
exactly the same thing the patients
are sicker and they're young the second
wave is proving to be deadlier than the
first
1820 more lives reported
lost today and it's feared
these stark numbers will continue in the
coming days
there will be more to to come because
what we're seeing
is the the result of the wave of the
uh of the new variant it looks as though
the the rates of infection
in the country overall uh may now be
uh be peaking or flattening but they're
not flattening very fast
and that means hospitals will continue
to see
very sick people like rini for some time
she's been on this high dependency ward
for a week
and still struggles to breathe
but she's grateful to be alive
how are you feeling a lot but i thought
i was
dead and this nurses to get me
through and doctors i cannot believe
what they did for me hospitals are full
of sick
covered patients many infected over
christmas
and the new year lockdown did eventually
come
but searching questions will need to be
asked
the action was too little too late
ashish joshi sky news at kingston
hospital